we are proposing an alternative model
for implementation of the protocol
on the one hand the flow of
goods between great britain and northern
ireland will be facilitated for goods
that are to stay in northern ireland on
the other
robust safeguards and monitoring
mechanisms should be put in place to
make sure that they stay in northern
ireland
in practice
british wholesalers of medicines will be
able to continue supplying northern
ireland from their current location in
great britain
they will not
need to relocate infrastructure
including testing facilities or
regulatory functions to northern ireland
or the european union
this means for instance
that great britain can continue acting
as a hub for supply of generic medicines
for northern ireland even though it is
now a third country
turning to the second part of our
package the area of
public plant and animal health and the
movement of sanitary and fetal sanitary
goods from great britain to northern
ireland
we are talking about a significant range
of retail goods that would be for sale
to end consumers in a northern ireland
only
these would benefit from both simplified
certification
and an approximately 80 percent
reduction
of checks and controls required today
let me illustrate what this means
imagine you are a northern irish
business importing products of animal
origin like yogurt cheese or chickens
from a great britain
more than 80 percent of the identity and
physical
checks previously required will now be
removed
this will significantly ease the process
for bringing food supplies from great
britain to northern ireland
so if you are transporting a hundred
different food products only one
certificate is needed instead of a
hundred
for all this to work in practice however
the uk government
needs to do its part for example by
ensuring
that permanent border control posts are
up and running as agreed a long time ago
we also need specific safeguards in
place like clear labels
and ability to monitor every link of the
supply chain
we are showing great flexibility but the
remaining controls must be done properly
i believe and it's understandable that
in this way we want to protect the
integrity of our eu single market